let's take a quick break from
monsterverse
and dive into other monster content here
today we will be listing out the 10
biggest dinosaurs seen in the two
jurassic world
movies the first one and fallen kingdom
so we also have dominion coming up in
the next year and i'm sure there will be
old classics mixed with new hybrid
dinosaurs
that will be seen in the movie but just
to recap on what happened
jurassic world was gigantic it was a
gigantic park built on the remnants of
jurassic park and then the indominus rex
escaped and all hell broke louis on the
island and then
on fallen kingdom dinos was saved and
brought back to the mainland
for auction but managed to escape and
roam everywhere
so let's see the 10 biggest of these
creatures
here on this list number 10
parasaurolophus these are herbivorous
dinosaurs and in that herd
of dinosaurs there would be a member
that would observe the surrounding area
for any threats
to the herd and would alert if there
were any nearby
it is one of the most distinctive
dinosaurs due to its spectacular
tube-like
shaped crest on its head that is up to 2
meters long
the crust is not only for exhibition but
can also produce a wide variety of
sounds
from sharp high-pitched shrieks to
infrasonic bays
parasaurolophus is a peaceful animal
that lives
in herds led by several adult males
standing 4 meters or 13 feet tall 10
meters or 30 feet long
and it weighs 4 to 5 tons
number 9 admontosaurus the advantasaurus
was one of the dinosaurs in the jurassic
world
theme park according to the park website
it existed in the gallimimus valley
it is a herbivore its diet consists of
ferns converse and other vegetation
the ademondosaurus clones oddly didn't
have the fleshy comb
on their heads like the original species
this dino was 3 meters or 10 feet tall
12 to 13 meters or around 40 feet long
and weighed 5 tons
number 8 stegosaurus stegosaurus is
often called the dumbest dinosaur
because of its incredibly small brain
it's the size of a walnut it's easily
one of the best known dinosaurs and is
recognized all over the world
it is the largest and most famous member
of the stigersaur family
it roamed the open plains of the late
jurassic period in what is now north
america
it has a long tail with spikes and rows
of plates on its back
which inspired the design of godzilla it
was 3 meters or 10 feet tall
8.5 meters or 28 feet long and weighed 6
tons number 7 the ankylosaurus
the ankylosaurus clones in isla saurona
had a dark down underbelly with bright
red patches on the eyes
it also had faded stripes of purple on
his body and its armor was black
it was like a tang with lots of thick
bony armor on its body
its back it also had a nasty weapon a
heavy club on the end of its tail
which could swing around and smash into
an attacking dinosaur
ankylosaurus was huge very big
it's a huge armored dinosaur measuring
about 33 to 35 feet long
around 7.5 to 10.7 meters and 6 feet
or 1.8 meters wide 6.6 feet or two
meters tall
and it weighed roughly 6.5 tons
number six the indominus rex the
indominus rex or
i-rex for short is a genetically
modified species of dinosaur created by
engine for by combining the base genome
of a tyrannosaurus
with that of a velociraptor the first
official hybrid created by indian it
contained the genetic material of also
carnotaurus giganotosaurus the
majingosaurus as well as
an assortment of modern species this led
to the birth of a new creature a modern
dinosaur that was a monster
that could regulate body temperature
camouflage itself
solve problems and kill everything in
sight it was 6.1 meters or 20 feet tall
15 meters or 50 feet long and weighed
eight
tons number five tyrannosaurus rex
commonly known as a t-rex this species
lived during the late cretaceous period
in modern day
north america and was therefore among
the last non-avian dinosaurs
like other tyrannosaurus tyrannosaurus
had very short arms with only two
fingers
despite the limb size each were able to
bench press about 400 pounds
this apex predator was notorious for its
powerful bite force
and also its size as as it was 20 feet
tall or 6 meters
40 feet long or 12 meters and weighed
around 9 tons in the movie
the oldest t-rex in the franchise is
rexy the one seen in the first movie the
jurassic park film
and also in the last one in fallen
kingdom
number four triceratops triceratops is
one of the most common dinosaur fossils
found
more than 50 skulls have been found till
date the serotopian family is one of the
most successful and varied
of the late cretaceous triceratops is
the largest member of this family
reaching the size of a school bus it is
quadripedal
has a muscular body and a skull with a
shield-like plate
with three massive horns although it was
short in height and length
than other previous entries it was still
heavier at around 12
tons so it was also 3 meters or 10 feet
tall
and 9 meters or 30 feet long
number three the mosasaurus these apex
predators of the prehistoric deep
can feast on all matter of ocean life
their double hinged jaws
open wide for any prey they could find
in the movies which include placeosaurus
and the great white sharks humans and
also the indominus rex too
they are not actually dinosaurs but in
fact marine reptiles
various estimates for its size was
thrown by fans and the movie makers
alike
the website states it to be 55 feet long
or 16.7 meters
and weighing 28 tons we don't doubt the
weight but
fans argue that the creature was at
least 21 to 24 meters or between 70 and
80 feet long
number two apatosaurus these dinosaurs
are one of the most famous of the giant
jurassic plant eaters
it was a sauropod a member of a race of
huge long neck dinosaurs
it was longer than two school buses and
weighed as much as four adult male
african elephants apotheosaurus is a
fairly typical member of the diplodocus
family
long necks pillar-like legs a long
tapering tail and enormous in size
it had like other family members back
leg teeth in a head
that seemed very small for such a large
creature it was 4.5 meters or 15 feet
tall
23 to 27 meters or between 75 and 90
feet long
and weighed 20 to 36 tons
and number one the brachiosaurus
and so the biggest on this list is yet
again another sauropod long neck
dinosaur
the brachiosaurus it gets its name from
the great height of its humerus
or the upper arm bone which is longer
than most humans at all
the size and high reach of the
brachiosaurus is its protection
only a starving or an insane carnivore
would attack such a huge mountain of
muscle brachiosaurus was one of the
first dinosaurs bred by injen for
jurassic park on isla nubla
and also found on isla sorna as well as
jurassic world
the successor to the first spark it was
13
or 43 feet tall as long as the t-rex
from head to tail
it was 21 meters or around 70 feet long
and weighed
56 tons and so with that we come to the
end of the video
on the 10 biggest dinosaurs from the
jurassic world series of films
which is jurassic world one and jurassic
world the fallen kingdom
we hope to see more on the upcoming
flick which means we want to see more
dinosaurs in the upcoming movie
and yes we will be doing more dinosaur
videos in the days to come
so stay tuned slap that like button
for support smash that subscribe button
to be a part of the mind cue family
and hit that notification bell like a
sunday church bell for regular updates
on dino and monster content till the
next one
take care fam